in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions mark
and Kelsey are with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
without Grand Rapids Michigan that area
that's a bit of a halt to Nashville a
little bit I'm telling you a welcome
we're glad you came South here to do a
debt-free screen - oh you bet how much
of you paid off $47,000 way to go making
what kind of money well we started off
it was just me Kelsie was still in
school I was making around $35,000 and
then we got married in this August so
this next year we'll be making probably
about 80 since we both have our
full-time jobs no excellent very cool so
how long did it take you to pay off
47,000 then and say about 18 months okay
man you've been busting it very cool and
you got married in August so great most
of this time you've done that with very
little income then right well it was
what Kelsey did what she went through
her last year of school without
acquiring any more debt and I I knew
that we were gonna have some student
loans to pay off once you know she
finished and so I was just putting
everything away and just just trying to
save up as much as I could
and then we just we paid it off this
November right when the grace period
ended the day that the grace period was
gonna end and we're gonna start
receiving bills we kicked it out in one
big lump sum and paid it all off before
even the bills came in so perfect it was
all student loans all state lands so you
gave Sallie Mae our marching papers
that's right you're out of here old
woman I love it I love it so what sets
you guys on this plan 18 months ago what
made you this smart well my husband here
has always listened to your show he was
harping Dave Ramsey since I met him when
we were in school
every time we were in the car we're
listening to your radio show I'm like
can we please listen to the music you
know we're not bored with it at first
really yeah I didn't know what this was
all about and then he it was his
birthday so I thought okay I'll I'll
purchase the FPU I told him I go with
them before we got married and it was
just going through the class and getting
on the same terms financially was just
huge for us especially for me I was
someone that wanted to save all my money
and every time I spent it I felt guilty
for spending anything because I was a
worried that it was gonna be a problem
later yeah and so getting on that plan
where we knew that okay this is we can
do this for entertainment we set this
money aside we have it it's okay you can
enjoy free you know so it was like we're
on this plan but it was just the most
freedom I'd ever felt with my finances
that's cool yeah one of our every dollar
budget errs the other day put in the
comments my budget told me I could yeah
I think this kind of gives you
permission to enjoy a few things because
you're being so responsible with the
rest of it I feel like that without the
budget I tend to be more on the hoarder
category rather than you know actually
being able to enjoy my money and do
stuff with that cool what do you two do
for a living I'm a teacher and I work on
our family farm oh very cool good good
what do you guys grow we grow fruit
cherries a spare asparagus what's not a
fruit but asparagus peaches and apples
okay very cool yep good good that's neat
well congratulations you two and how
does it feel it feels great I I just
always say you know it was so important
for us to you know be able to be on the
same page when we got married you know
and just kind of knowing you know what's
our goals and what our direction is and
you know just being rid of that debt
right away and you know we just we just
finished baby step three and we're gonna
start you know investing for retirement
and you know saving for a house now when
it's just nice to know that you know we
have we have a plan and we have a goal
on what we're gonna do with our money
instead of you know just you know
reaching a certain point in our life and
like you always say like we worked so
hard and you know where where's our
money going you know it's just nice to
have that feeling so how old are you -
I'm 23 I'm 24 oh my gosh you are so on
fire you're gonna have so much you're
gonna be able to give so much and be
able to change your whole family tree I
mean this is you guys are amazing
you got a great start yeah we really do
and we attribute that to you I
attributed it to you know my parents do
and my family they were there you know
big there they just know how to do it
well I mean yeah we can give your
parents some credit or try to give me
some credit but the bottom line is you
two did it you're the hero I mean
you're incredible you got such a great
start because if you can do this kind of
stuff together you can do anything right
I mean there's nothing that holds you
back now this is absolutely awesome
so what do you tell people the secret to
paying off $47,000 in debt is I'd say
for us it was doing the budget and
staying focused and people make fun of
you while you were doing this oh I had
people always say oh do you have a
coupon for that can you go do you have a
coupon
you know just yeah I mean I had people
jobs
it's just the mindset you know and even
when we told people we were coming here
they're like oh really like we still
have debt and we're you know 50 or
whatever it is and it's just the mindset
of that it's not important the debt is
just what everyone has change in that
and I always say like you know you gotta
kind of get in the mindset that you know
you can't just go along with what the
culture is telling you all the time you
know you have to kind of take ownership
of your own life and not expect that you
know the next president or the next
person you vote for is gonna come in and
try to take care of you and it's got to
be you that decides to take care of your
life ladies and gentlemen he's 24 and he
figured it out this is awesome I wish we
could get some 53 year olds to figure it
out excellent you guys very well done
all right mark and Kelsey Grand Rapids
Michigan $47,000 paid off in eighteen
months making 35 now making 80 after
getting married count it down let's hear
a debt free scream yep three three two
great job love it love it love it this
is how it is done well done you two
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim